here's part of your problem with theater
is the the the fruit SAR as I like to
call it of the the whole thing of a
whole group of people I don't even know
that word so you've already lost me with
the fruit well of course you've lost me
I because it's a word i' I made up
you're a writer I made that word up oh
God for that that group of so I can't
use that as clickbait no it won't work
fruit hash fruit you can you'll be the
only one using it so therefore oh and I
rarely use it but I thought throw it out
at you it's that whole thing of a whole
group of people and we're going to put
the show on and it's going to be great
and everybody's going to have a time and
and that's what I think is your problem
with theater as opposed to theater
theater real theater when you see a show
you don't even like to see a show I to
be honest with you it's where like I
love film and and I love and I love um
it's maybe it's theater acting you know
I maybe it's your experience in the
theater being surrounded by a lot of
people maybe it's that maybe that
tainted the whole experience for you Dad
I'm surrounded by a lot of people at a
movie and I've told you not to use the
word taint around my
friends
wow she's just learning she's a kid you
know um I don't [__] foot around stuff
again yeah I know well she's gone to the
left of the
taint but no it's the acting it's like
uh you know and maybe because of theater
I don't know that much about theater but
you know like play to the
balcony what what did you just say it's
like you know it's well yeah but that's
what I said you've seen a lot of shitty
theater and I mean if you see really
good the you don't even think about it
cuz it's like oh my God you know I mean
it's just when it's good it's good but
you I mean what's amazing about theater
is what I enjoyed about theater how I is
is that a group of people together get
together create a reality everybody
shares in the reality if it's done right
so you're basically hallucinating
together that was a hook for to me
that's a movie well that's also a play I
mean if it's done right it's you are
creating that reality and what was
strange was I went to a ton of movies
because I found the um kind of The
Narrative of movies or the way in which
a movie told a story to be more
interesting than the way a play told a
story
and I kept trying to write things that
would kind of use that I guess because
as a comedian or having that mind which
is what I noticed about you and most
people in my business the the the
ability to kind of
notice um over like you get mad at this
all the time and you go enough H you
know look at that little speck and then
I make or look at how you pronounce that
word or look at how you you know the the
little micro
kind of uh fiber of life and how people
react so that when a even a a set slides
in behind all of a sudden I'm not into
the drama of you know your son going off
to war your son just went off to war and
now there's a painting of armored tanks
behind you yeah that kind of took me out
I don't know what plays you're seeing
but this is the one where the sun goes
off to war front of a painting of armor
tanks yeah that one that was it was
really was a spellbinder yes and then
musicals for me when somebody starts
singing it kind of takes you out of for
me right it takes me out of a right but
you never saw a
Hamilton you know what I didn't mind
that you're right you're right and the
reason is can I tell you why no why I
mean I thought you meant did you know
why I I'm not listening I should listen
I can't hear I'm wearing a headset tell
me why no but I think the because it
really did break through it went another
step with musicals it was a huge leap
forward in terms of the musical it was
not your Oklahoma you know please see
Oklahoma I know is a big play it's huge
I've watched parts of it I can't get
into it right but the you like Oklahoma
well I I I kind of grew up on that stuff
because your parents took you to theater
yeah so that's where it's an addiction
are you an only child no I had a brother
okay he was smart enough not to okay and
and he didn't like theater no he liked
theater but he didn't he didn't he
didn't go my father and I would go uh
literally once every six weeks I mean I
saw the original Hello Dolly with um
Carol Channing car Channing I saw the
diamonds are girl's best for yeah I saw
a bunch of
original uh works you know and that
makes a big difference and you you know
and it was a way to bond with my dad so
it was
great
he